so I'm a big believer in getting outside  every single day I have a timer that I  set off every morning that by the when  my feet hit the ground  within 15 minutes I have a timer I need  to get outside from feet hit the ground  need to be outside in 15 minutes that  means wake up brush my teeth go to the  bathroom change feed the dogs have some  water and be outside within 15 minutes  yes even in Canadian winter put your  jackets on put your hats on get outside  the other thing it is I want to believe  walk every day and that's where I'll go  on a walk 15-20 minutes I will look at  my social media I will respond to people  with video direct messages on Instagram  to remind myself that the work that I'm  doing is actually touching humans lives  if you're not happy if you're feeling  down you're feeling low you don't have  the energy you're not liking life right  now it's an easy hack get outside even  in the cold get some sunlight on your  face you'll feel better try it